in the heart of the Pyrenees mountain
region is Frances very last fairy maker
the flat woolen hat was invented here by
local shepherds and Lola has been making
it since the mid 19th century a made in
France tradition that an Irishman is
trying to keep alive fighting cheap
replicas from the Czech Republic China
and India when you look at a very from
from anywhere from Asia India or
elsewhere you will actually see the
trail you'll see how it's made that's
what makes a big difference mark
Saunders joined Lola a year ago after it
was rescued by a military clothing maker
the company was nearly bankrupt now he's
trying to turn it around traveling as
far as Russia to sell the iconic hat we
won't export it everywhere as the we
have no limit to that really Japan they
love berries in Japan but we're hoping
that's that the people from from from
even from New York and the East Coast
will see and look at as an urban it
takes two to three days to make a real
fairy it starts with knitting merino
wool into a flat circle then it has to
be felted using water from the local
river before it is dyed shaped and
shaved to create the highest quality the
majority of the product is made by hand
the company says it hopes to produce
200,000 hats this year priced between 20
and 95 euros check that out and it's
targeting female customers currently
women represent just a quarter of the
business today our latest fashion
business that we diversified 30 years
ago that's gonna take us forward and
onto the global side of things I'd love
to see what a brown like your hammers
could do in terms of homage to the
phrase beright so grabbing headlines at
this year's fashion shows could be the
boost that beret needs Tom Gibson
Bloomberg